what about or you can post your thoughts
in the G+ event or the YouTube comments
and producer Dan is going to read those
out for you if you're too shy to join us
live on the telly box while we give
folks a chance to get their thoughts
together and join us on the Hangout so
I'm going to cover a few points that
have already been raised by some of the
developer audience on the Google+ page
those of you who have joined us on the
hang up thank you for joining us we'll
get Daniel in touch with you via text on
that so that we can cure you up and get
you ready to share your thoughts so let
me really sorry about that I I cut out
the first 10 seconds of your intro so
the welcome and you know if you're
watching please deviation all that stuff
sorry about that that's all right not a
problem so yeah so just so everyone
knows this is after the table flip talk
radio style chance for everyone else to
tell me how right I was or how wrong I
was I somehow suspect we'll get more of
the latter than the former just because
if you agree then there's not a lot to
say so we're going to get some folks on
hang out as well I'm going to start off
by answering some of the questions from
people on the G+ event and the YouTube
live stream so if you do have questions
and you prefer not to be on video do
throw them in there and producer Dan
will respond on your behalf so I'm G+
developer Jacob Northfork represented
probably the most common argument
against what i was presenting in today's
table flip and that is that there's a
lot of user pressure or dissatisfaction
because users quote don't know how to
quit the program and I think I covered
sort of the argument against that pretty
well but let's be a little bit more
specific in two examples so in Jacobs
case he's talking about to internet
radio apps that he has built an in his
experience uses a failed to find the
stop button to stop the music now he's
pointed out that in his particular use
case he's not allowed to make the stop
button more prominent and so this is a
genuine problem so what I would say is
have a look at the way that Google Music
actually solves this and so really it's
about making sure that stop stopping the
music stopping the resource consumption
is really really easy to
mind so Google Music does this by having
the stop controls along the bottom of
every activity whenever the act is
running or if the app isn't running but
the music is playing then there's an
ongoing notification which has rich
notifications as well which again allows
you to stop the music and in addition to
that there's also the lock screen which
you can then configure in which Google
music does to allow you to stop playback
as well and so the solution here
particularly for music playing apps is
that all of those things I've just
described a totally available to any
third party app and so by doing things
like this it makes it really really easy
even if the stop button doesn't have to
be half the screen it's just everywhere
they look there's a really obvious place
to find it and that's going to be much
more reliable than having an exit button
which a lot of users aren't going to
find anyway user demands for an exit
button almost always correlate to an app
that has confusing navigation or
hard-to-find controls or as a resource
hog so adding an exit button is going to
stop users from asking you to add an
exit button but it's it's kind of like
giving an aspirin to a place patient
complaining of chronic abdominal pains
they will stop asking for the
painkillers but it doesn't actually get
rid of that problem so you're better off
trying to treat the underlying cause
rather than the symptom and similarly
daniel duro asks how would you implement
the browser feature of ditching all
cookies on exit if you don't have an
exit button that's actually a really
good question in practice I think
there's an assumption that mobile
devices are inherently more personal
than computers so privacy features like
like this sort of exit remove all
cookies when you exit which were really
designed around ensuring the credentials
used by different users on the same
computer don't leak when your wife
girlfriend husband whoever uses your
computer so those sorts of features
aren't quite as important for a phone
with the implicit assumption is that
there's only going to be one person
using it so in fact it even almost goes
the other way where the pain associated
with having to put in your credentials
or into the same information in multiple
times is actually significantly more
annoying on a phone than it is on a
computer so there's sort of even more
reason to hang on to some of this stuff
so that's it if you did want to do
something like that the suggestion I
would have is probably to have
a menu option probably a settings option
to clear all cookies or better still
maybe a menu item which says something
like close all windows and clear all
cookies or it just says close all
windows and clear all cookies is one of
the options that you have so that's
answer to two of those questions where
should we go to next data we got folks
on the Hangout which would like to vent
their spleen I have any one explicitly
asking for time on camera but if any of
you guys in the Hangout right now want
to comment we can definitely put you on
air so just let us know wait I think we
should put people on the spot if they're
joining the Hangout we're going to
assume that they've got something to say
so pick someone who who looks like looks
like they're enjoying themselves a guy
in the in the red shirt let's pop him
online and see what he's got to all
right to share with us all the guy in
the red shirt would be
e.j Miguel uh I'm not gonna say his
whole name he can introduce himself you
want to pop him up on the screen and let
him know and unmute him because I
suspect his muted all right think he's
still muted hey how you doing heres we
can't hear him have you go oh here we go
okay now we can hear you okay what do
you think am I am I full of it or a mind
to something so you're absolutely right
and I was just good as if there are any
other options yeah I mean are there
people that think that the exit button
makes any sense there are there are a
surprisingly high number of people which
disagree with the basic premise I think
it's usually around users that seems to
be the feedback I get from most
developers is that they're like yeah we
don't want to do it but I users keep
asking for them and so I think a big
part of it is is trying to explain
explain and a lot of the time what
they're saying is well that's fine but
you need to explain to users why they
don't need an exit button but what I've
actually found is that it's easy to
explain to developers how to build apps
that people aren't asking for those exit
buttons because that kind of tends to be
the most common thing they're like I
didn't want to do it but people kept
asking for it so I had to build it in so
it's really about trying to explain to
devs how you can build apps which don't
have people asking this question if they
if the client does ask for it it seems
right they're paying for it they get it
absolutely no of course that's I guess
that's the other the other case which I
haven't really talked much about is what
happens when you're building an app for
someone and they say we want an exit
button well you have to do with the
client says but really it's about trying
to create
people feel comfortable at least telling
their clients that you know this is an
anti-pattern this is not what android
users are going to expect and being able
to you know say that with some Authority
and that's a big part of what the design
guidelines on developer.android.com /
designer really about is helping to
create sort of a an expectation of this
is what Android apps are so if you're
asking for something different then it's
it's you know counter to what people are
going to be expecting and you know I
think there's a lot of sort of
background which we have to get past of
people being used to old feature phone
j2me apps which have an exit button
because they were sort of single tasking
or you know even iphone which uses a
slightly different model for the way
that they do things and so a lot of it
is sort of education both the developers
and users and and clients which seem to
somehow fit in between anyone else in
the Hangout I'm gonna put you guys on
the spot and just select move someone at
random if no one volunteers ya chand
jumping I guess real quick for the head
out all right hey doing good night right
Ryan your go ahead your life cool so
let's run to agree with with reto with
the whole activity of life cycle thing
you know a lot of people say that you
need that exit button to team exit that
app and get it out of their mind I guess
a lot of people probably just don't
fully understand that life cycle where
it goes in the background stays in the
back off a little bit and then you know
you have to you have to adjust for that
whole life cycle pattern of going
through on pause and then on stop and
making sure you clear up the things that
you're appropriately doing with your app
in those life cycles yeah i think the
life cycle stuff it's kind of the most
fundamental thing about android which
makes it really different to anything
I've ever done before I was a windows
program of before Android and you know
you're not really thinking in those
sorts of terms of the OS telling you
what's happening to your app like you
capture some of those things like on
formal
even on control focus and stuff but it's
it's never too you know control your
resource usage it's just to decide
whether your app should be doing
something so now I always think that's
kind of a big challenge once you really
get the the lifecycle stuff in your head
everything else just kind of makes sense
and kind of follows is that kind of
similar your experience yeah no
definitely agree in that aspect a lot of
people just probably just don't see that
us being developers you know you you
know that life cycle you know it's
happening in the app and the background
what is supposed to happen um you know
maybe the users probably just don't see
that right in the foreground of oh this
there's a life cycle going on this is
what needs to happen and so maybe
they're feeling like um there should be
an exit button when a reality you really
don't need one um so you definitely not
you know crazy I see where you're coming
from so small that you know that cool
thanks right appreciate that alright
cool do we have any other questions on
either the live stream or on G+ or
YouTube well someone's going to stand up
in the air in the yeah alright yeah
let's put them on this is Dave hey Dave
go ahead and you're like yeah I just
want a quick comment about what the
previous speaker said I think you know
it's going to take a little while for
people to get used to that I think we're
so even a few years ago or a couple
years ago maybe with a vesture or
something like that we're so used to
closing down stuff and making sure Ram
is available in all that's enough that
we need to really get used to knowing
that if an app is done properly sitting
in the background not consuming
resources not pinging the server and so
on and so forth that's I think that's
really going to take a couple of years
before people understand and are aware
of that and are comfortable just leaving
apps open you know just by hitting the
back button and back to the home screen
so oh absolutely I think there's a big
challenge there for us as developers as
well it's making sure that the users
feel really comfortable doing that in it
I mean this this is the thing if you
have a whole bunch of apps and then you
go back to the home screen and your
device starts running real slow that's
that's a terrible experience you know
it's no wonder it uses the thing and
it'd be like I just want to know how to
exit all of these arts and so I think
the framework team
here at Google done a lot of work in
that direction to try and make the blame
more visible so things like battery
drain and those sorts of things you can
see which apps are doing it and so the
blame goes to them rather than to the
system and if you're doing these things
right if you're suspending all of your
listeners turning off your updates not
doing background brief brushes or any of
that stuff then your app will never get
blamed for anything and no one's ever
going to you know call into question as
to how can i how can I get rid of this
because it's just there and it just
works but yeah I think that's the
challenge and you're going to reach that
critical mass where most apps are doing
the right thing and then users are going
to be like why would I exit it that just
just going to slow stuff down mm-hmm
cool um so
Ali hey I notice that you have a
question in the chat do you want to
aspirate alive you're on your own air I
just asked what I could do to i'm
actually just starting to start you know
develop and whatnot so i wanted to know
are there any resources that you can
actually provide or that Google provides
about learning more about the life cycle
absolutely so I posted a link so links
to all of those stuff that i showed in
the sort of the intro video there on the
youtube site a person it should be
possible as well but to answer your
question more specifically if you go to
developer.android.com / training we have
a bunch of sort of intro level classes
to help really sort of explain the basic
building blocks of android and I think
the life cycle stuff is lesson one it's
kind of that fundamental so if you want
to sort of get a better understanding of
what it means how does it work what's
the right way of dealing with it then
yeah definitely check that out and that
should help you get started thank you no
worries and good luck with everything
that it should be a lot of fun we look
forward to seeing what you come up with
thanks alright guys who's up next well
just go and raise your hand on on the
Hangout and I'll put you guys live
anyone all right here we go sorry much
quite sure how to pronounce your name
what why don't you go ahead and
introduce yourself Oh y'all see if
you've even used the law nice for myself
from Google+ nicely done then how you
doing I commuted yourself yeah
still nothing why don't you go and check
your mic and still nothing now we're not
hearing you unfortunately you'll see
all right why don't we move on to
something else ok here we go there you
know thank you ok ok sorry a couple of
mics over here so i needed to choose the
correct one first of all hi Reed oh I
don't know if you remember me from the
google i/o oh I meet a lot of people
that I here yeah yeah I know I know it
um basically what i wanted to refer to
was the exit button in our app we used
we who is a video social communication
chat and i am messaging and so on and
basically we have users and wanting to
exit the application in fully not just
doing a sign out and leaving the service
and running or something like that or
killing the basically they want to exit
the application so our service will die
at the same point day one so i'm
referring to it as a bad pattern because
that's more like a single task device
and not the hand root system but
basically if we need to implement such a
behavior then the exit button should be
a part of the android pal although the
android system is killing tasks by
itself i think the the challenge in a
situation like that is sort of similar
to all you're going to see things like
google talk or any any ongoing messaging
thing where you want the user wants the
ability to basically say disconnect from
your server and stop consuming
everything so in that case a combination
of sort of hitting log out or sign out
from the service and then and listening
for on pause should be enough so the
once once they say disconnect that
should be the equivalent of hitting exit
basically yeah that's that's what that's
what we implemented we have both
features we have the feature sign out so
we'll
show the user the home screen to login
via Facebook or his username and
password and we also have the exit
button that keeps the load the user
logged into the system but basically
exit all the applications and kills the
service another thing and then all
messaging or notifications comes GCM
word c2dm to all those devices so that's
it then actually that brings up a really
good point in kind of what I was
alluding to earlier like if you hadn't
told me that if i just opened your
apples will walk out and exit as two
separate options i would have no idea
what the exit button would do i
certainly wouldn't expect that if i hit
exit that i still get messages from GCM
i would expect it if you hit exit
everything turns off so i log out and i
stopped getting messages and I think
that's the challenge right if you
introduce something like exit which
doesn't have a clear semantic meaning
then different users are going to open
it in different ways and so like logout
totally makes sense disconnect me from
your services I don't want to get any
more messages 100% makes sense exit it
doesn't like basically what you're
describing what the exit button does
sounds to me like what should happen
when I hit back or home from within your
app yeah yeah that's what that's what
I'm saying but because we're we're doing
cross-platform so we we want our users
to know that the device or application
handles the same situations all over the
platforms so basically if you have an
exit button on iphone or you have an
exit button on Windows or on windows
phone tablets and so on or even are
given on Matthew press and command qu
you exit the app and on Android the
ecosystem is just hit the home button
and let Android deal with all the memory
and all the task on going and so on so
how what is the best
option to handle the situation for us
and also give the user the same
atmosphere the same experience when
moving from device to device is
basically the user can connect from an
ipod and I an iphone and ipad Nexus 7
Nexus 10 a Google TV you name the device
we have so basically we want the user to
know that Ovoo connects people all over
the world no matter what the same same
experience the same features are
available on all devices so that's the
main issue here so yeah no that's okay
so that's a good question and it's it's
actually an interesting one because I
sort of hear this a lot from from
developers who are building sort of
these cross platforms where they want to
have something really consistent across
all of the different devices now the
thing is is sort of two different ways
that I would approach this and the first
is that it was actually fairly unlikely
that you're going to have a significant
number of users which have multiple
different devices from the manufacturer
so you know you're not going to have a
lot of people which having a red phone
yes there will be some that but and this
leads me to my second point which is
that people expect their devices to
behave consider those it necessarily
affect maps to work exactly the same
across different devices so if I've got
an iPad then I expect all of the apps to
work in a way that's consistent with the
way all of the other ipad apps work and
if I had android than I expect them to
all work with Android so what you don't
have is an iphone user expecting their
android phone to work in the same way as
their iphone because it's a different
device right there they're not they
don't have the same expectations if they
did they get really confused when they
started using things like mail and maps
and and music and Twitter and everything
else because they just inherently
behaved if
and it's the same with computers you
know you expect your computer to work in
a certain way you expect to have that
command queue to get out of a nap in Mac
if you've got windows you expect to be
able to hit alt f4 but you know what
you're not expecting is you know a good
example is if you're building an app for
both windows and mac you're not going to
build the command q shortcut into the
windows app so the people who are you
know using it on Mac understand how to
quit you're going to build in the same
sort of user patterns that they're
expecting for windows and it's the same
across mobile like I wouldn't tell you
to build your iPhone app so that they
work and look the same as your Android
apps you want we want to have a
consistent experience between the
platform because that's what they're
doing within a given context so you know
for your app in particular what you want
to do what your users is going to expect
is that if you're signed in but your app
is not in the foreground then it
shouldn't be consuming any resources and
that's just going to be their
expectation some may look to find an
exit button but if you're not doing
anything if you're not consuming any
resources if the phone is not going
slower if you're not doing background
Paul you're not waking up the phone
you're just receiving those updates
using google cloud messaging then
they're going to be happy you know
they're not going to be looking for
something if there's no reason to look
for it so that would be my big piece of
devices don't try to over simplify
across devices because that in my
experience it tends to be what what
bosses what CEOs do because they look at
all of your apps across all of the
different phones in yeah that's that's
our issue here because the designers are
ours our product guys basically want the
same features to be on all devices and
my main concern or my main issue as an
Android developer is to show them that
the Android system is not the same as
the iOS system or is not the same so you
have the basic conventions in android
such as the HOME key or the not showing
the exit option I'm with you I agree
that you don't need an exit button on
your application but basically I want
you to say so I can have a verdict
a judge overruled England on the matter
so I can show it to our designers and
let them know that basically what
they're doing is not is not native to
android sure and that's and that's the
sort of thing which we're trying to do a
lot more of these days I think the thing
about android particular when we got
started is that it's like it's open you
can do anything but now we're trying to
get to the point where it's like you can
do anything but we'd really like people
to do things in a consistent way to make
it easier for users and so we're trying
to become a little bit more aggressive
about telling people what what are the
best practices you don't have to follow
them no one's going to take your app out
of google play if you do things
differently but at least something you
can show your design team and your your
management team and say look this is the
way that that things work on Android and
if you want to do it differently you're
going to have to come up with something
very different oh I see what's happened
here yuck you know yeah so let me go let
me just jump over here and I'll fix that
problem keynote wonderful boom yes so
that's it sounds like it sounds like
you're you're on the same page as me so
so it sounds like we're in good shape at
yeah that's the challenges is explaining
to two other people exactly why that's
the case and hopefully you can share
with them some of the stuff that we
talked about today and that may and pay
help change their minds thanks for your
time yes it's been a pleasure talking
thank you so I'd put luke on Luke has a
quick question for you hey look hey um I
was just wondering about something that
I've seen that's similar to what you're
talking about but not exactly the same
where when someone hits the back button
from an application I love it hangouts
hangouts doing us a favor yeah one
second guys we'll be right back
love the technology around here it never
screws us over yep so while we're
waiting for Luke to come back cool I
thank you back all right so we missed
some of that because our hangout crash
but I'm going to go ahead and assume
that that sentence finished with you hit
a back button that says are you sure you
want to exit yes all right yeah I hate
that too that makes me very very angry
there are very few exceptions to that
rule so navigation is actually a good
one where if I hit the back button on
google navigation it says do you want to
end all route guidance and then you can
either say yes or no and that's
reasonable because I think it's still
it's still exits the it still backs out
of the app it just either does or
doesn't turn off the ongoing service and
that's because if I accidentally hit
back while I'm driving I don't want to
then have to faff around with maps and
navigation to try and get it back up so
I like that where it's sort of a
disruptive distracting behavior but if
it's just a normal app that's like it
shouldn't be a difference right for most
apps if they don't have an ongoing
service heading back and then going oh
whoops and then starting it again it
should be the same as starting it from
scratch or hitting home and going back
so yeah that's definitely an
anti-pattern that i really hope dies a
death all right I was expecting yeah
nothing too controversial there thanks
for bringing it up okay we got another
hand wave I think fourth from the left
said is that Union Dave I think so all
right I think that's it again hey no
that was just my son waving ha excellent
say hi to you son yeah all right who's
up next unfortunately since the Hangout
crash that I lost some of the comments
so if you guys were interested in
joining in live just let me know wave
your hand I'll put you guys on air do we
have any comments on G+ or on YouTube
which may require some responding there
are actually a lot of great comments I'm
actually having a hard time picking a
good one they all seem to be replying to
each other
this very debatable topic oh okay
excellent so let me go ahead and look
through a couple of them to look and
pick pick a great one for you I think I
did see one down here a little bit let
me scroll down so while well dad just
looking that up I just want to as well
point out to you guys that I'm going to
try and do this semi regularly so if
there are particular topics which make
you want to flip a table let me know on
g+ twitter wherever you like and i'll
see if i can put together some argument
yes Dave I actually have a quick
question maybe we all have the same
question are you gonna flip that table
before we before you leave I was
thinking about it but my was on it so
I'm gonna I'm gonna choose not to and
maybe save that up for next week i will
also take suggestions on different kinds
of tables i know that there was some
people who were disappointed that i used
a table which had like a cylindrical
bottom rather than a more traditional
four-legged table which the you know the
emoticon would would seem to require but
you know it's a learning experience
which its iterate and and launch and
iterate often so that's so we're going
to do here a table flip as well you know
i really love to hear what what are some
of the things that drive you guys crazy
and you know as a joseline was sort of
you know suggesting earlier like I think
a lot of the time we as developers all
know what how we think apps should work
and we get overruled by designers or PMS
which perhaps aren't as familiar with
Android as as we are you know so if
you're if you're looking for a way to be
able to you know present a justification
and do let me know and perhaps a six
minute video will help I don't know how
much so that it's probably worth it dry
let's say did you find a good question
or comment for I understand a simple one
which
is not too far beyond my understanding
but it's about um debouncing the back
button for example if you're hitting
back multiple times and quickly try to
escape with an app which most users tend
to do it'll take you back a lot further
than you intended to so is it what are
your thoughts on giving some feedback to
users when they're hitting back and it's
short amount of time so i think i'm
going to answer that question by
answering a slightly different question
which is really about navigation and i
think that's a another vector into which
people are like I want an exit button
because otherwise been in a browser or
in a nap but I have to eat it hit exit
like a million times before I get out of
the app if that's happening that tells
me that the navigation of your app is
probably overly complex it shouldn't
require sort of 15 20 back button hits
to get back to the home screen of your
app so whether that's using the UH
performance or using a logo click to
take you back to the main screen if your
app you really want to be able to make
it easy for users to navigate
particularly on phones and I think still
on tablets you really don't want to
force your users down a rabbit hole of
navigation you want to keep it as simple
as possible so rather than figuring out
how do I deal with the fact that he used
and may hit the back button seven times
instead of six times to get to the home
screen think about how to make it easy
if you use it to get to the home screen
to begin with I think that that's
probably a better way to invest your
time and figuring out how to deep outs
you know too many back button clicks
well so we've got another good comment
from Paul W here he says that users
traditionally have grown up being taught
what the exit button does throughout
their entire lives mmm and so you know
you're you're on Windows or you're on
some of the operating system and
you you know everyone kind of feels
familiar with the exit button that's
certainly it's kind of you know part of
the foundation of how we do things
already yes so maybes you sort of
disagreeing with you now I'd like that I
mean I think that's what I was kind of
talking about right at the beginning so
you may have missed the start and we'll
have just the video of the rant posted
in fact there's a link to it in the G+
stream if you did miss the very
beginning but it's a good point right
like old school exit meant something
like if you have a single tasking
operating system you need to have an
exit in order to be able to do something
else and so yeah users have gotten you
so particularly us like I'm guessing the
people watching this have been using
computers since shortly after exiting
the womb and so those sort of patterns
really getting grained with us but new
users you know they're not thinking of
it that way particularly phone users who
don't really think of their phone as
being a computer that runs apps they
just think of it as a device that lets
them do stuff I mean I remember reading
a survey he was late last year or early
this year which ask people do you use
the internet on your phone and most said
no no don't use the internet on my phone
and then the follow-up question is like
well do you check your email do you
update facebook do you use twitter and
they're like yeah definitely do all of
those things and it's like the internet
how does it work you know that's what's
making all of these things work but
people don't think of it that way
they've completely you know all of the
implementation details about how these
apps work the fact that their apps
running on a multitasking operating
system connecting to the internet over a
net or cell network tcp/ip connection I
don't know any of that they don't care
about any of that they just want to do
something like order a taxi or check
their email or update twitter or take a
photo and how it all works means nothing
to them and so in that context exit
doesn't make any sense like I just want
to update twitter and then i want to
take a photo I don't want to have to
think about exiting one app to start up
another so it's really about changing
those paradigms and getting people
thinking in a different way so that then
you can say anything is old school like
you know I remember when I was in high
school thinking I can't believe it man
this
new computer i'm going to buy it doesn't
have a five and a quarter inch disk
that's ridiculous I mean I know I mainly
use the three and a half inch floppies
now but the five and a quarter is never
going away yeah it went away and then
the 303 and a half inch run away not too
long afterwards and then hard drives
started to end up in the terabytes but
you know my point is that things change
and i think as developers we need to
adapt to that and the trend is really to
try and make things easier and easier
for users so they don't have to think
about how do i use a computer they just
do stuff and and then the OS does all
the hard work it's the same when we
started switching to garbage collected
programming languages like a lot of
folks back in the day were like oh
that's ridiculous you don't have to
manage your own memory but you know what
it's it's easier it makes our job easier
and let's just focus on features rather
than on you know the the bits and pieces
that go into making an appt work I think
we're just about out of time we've
already gone 15 minutes later than I
initially proposed but we've had a lot
of good comments and conversations so I
didn't want to cut anyone off but is
there anyone on the on the hangouts
which would like to throw in a few final
thoughts comments disagreements and just
say thank you oh you're very welcome I
had a question um and I was wondering if
you could do a session on unit testing
okay yeah unit testing is a good one I
think testing is something which show we
probably don't have as much information
out there for Android as we should do
considering how important it is so yeah
we'll definitely feed that back into the
team and see we can get like you know an
office hours hangout or something around
unit testing best practices those sorts
of things it's a great idea cool and I
think that's it thank you alright thank
you very much everyone let's see yeah so
that's it for today I'll be back next
time for another Android and he pattern
that makes me want to flip a table I
don't know what it is yet so if you've
got suggestions let me know and I will
throw the furniture on your behalf until
then my name is reto Meier we were able
assisted by Daniel Pham and thank you
for watching
you